[Musique]
audrey pulvar et arnaud montebourg
valérie trierweiler et françois hollande
journalistes et politiques ont souvent
fait bon ménage des affaires privées se
traite en privé aujourd'hui c'est thomas
sotto qui a annoncé au parisien qu'il ne
présentera pas l'émission politique
elise et 2022 sur france 2 car il serait
en couple avec mayada boulot conseiller
en communication de jean castex et c'est
une bonne chose par souci d'éthique et
d'impartialité le présentateur doit donc
se retirer provisoirement de l'antenne
une première pour un homme c'est une
décision difficile et d'une certaine
manière assez injuste et je me dois de
tenir compte de notre époque devenue
très violente et qui a tendance à tout
hystériser il restera néanmoins à
l'animation de télématin et de son
émission sur france inter
alors j'espère mais je suis extrêmement
choqué par cette affaire en effet thomas
sotto ne se retirent corps parce qu'elle
a été révélée en 7 plusieurs mois
plusieurs semaines voilà au moins on va
dire plusieurs semaines trois quatre
mois douze semaines donc c'est chaud
quand moi je fais deux semaines c'est
chaud monde pourquoi donc parce qu'ils
ne se retirent que parce qu'il est
obligé parce que ça a été révélé mais
deux lui même il aurait dû dire
quelqu'un d'honorable aurait dû dire je
suis j'ai une relation avec une
conseillère de jean castex je m'en vais
pour quoi vous imaginez qu'il casse jean
castex lors d'une interview lors d'une
chronique mais quand il rentre chez lui
le gars le soir il est viré de sa maison
et c'est surtout ce qu'il est il est
avec la directrice c'est surtout s'ils
en sont
écoulés la tonne de jean castex oui s'il
le critique il peut pas rentrer chez lui
elle va lui dire mais tu te fous de ma
gueule etc elle va le virer donc tout ce
qu'il dit tout oui à tout ce qu'il dit
est orienté
de lui retirer au site télé maintenant
les matins ils ont défait les positions
datant d'environ 2 sur le milliard c'est
bon on aurait dû le virer deux tours
oui non mais comme d'habitude il est
excessif oui que pour une émission
politique effectivement non c'est normal
oui aussi de se maintenir parce que je
suis une telle défiance vis-à-vis
justement des journalises voilà la
connivence des conflits d'intérêts que
finalement ces paroles seraient toujours
un peu biaisé on dirait glee mais dis ça
parce que ils intérêt où il a il doit
être agressif parce que justement il
veut contrebalancer évidemment par
rapport au gouvernement atteint donc
forcément il doit partir et c'est mieux
effectivement les femmes le font elles
sont qu'on leur demande sans qu'on le
découvre elles font avec un peu de
panache parce qu'on l'a découvert on
savait qu'au xixe sur les hameaux il
faut savoir quitter la table quand le
meilleur est desservie
médaille mais effectivement il ya c'est
très symptomatique d'une d'une défiance
qui a auprès de la presse et dont on
imagine que de toute façon ils sont pas
capables de faire la part des choses et
donc si on imagine qu'ils sont pas
capables de faire la part des choses ils
n'ont pas vraiment le choix en
l'occurrence est une première puisque
effectivement on l'a demandé à béatrice
schönberg à la demande très demandée à
la za clair on l'a demandé
j'ai croisé un cinquième veston non il
ya trois semaines est libre non mais je
vous dis pas magnifique tu ne le sont
mais une lotion le sens bourg qui on
laisse au département donne en crochet à
est magnifique et donc voilà et pour
bois pour une fois c'est un homme qu'on
le demande - chez moi à titre personnel
je déplore qu'on ne puisse pas imaginer
qu'on est capable de canton et
journalise de faire la part des choses
quand il avait un an mais le
gouvernement
ni les bretzels
ministériel maison qui va être au
courant forcément parce qu'elle va lui
dire blanc dit rien donc c'est une faute
grave c'est en reste et on n'est jamais
qu'un remaniement ministériel
elle lui dit rien mais croyez vraiment
qu'il va défoncer jean castex en sortant
de sa directrice de communication jamais
et moi je suis choquée qu'ils aient
caché pendant des mois et à sa rédaction
et aux téléspectateurs c'est mentir aux
téléspectateurs on rappelle qu'il est
quand même censé recevoir de manière
impartiale les plus grands dirigeants
politiques imaginez en 2017 si un des
animateurs du débat présidentiel sortait
avec marine le pen ce serait choquant
les gens se sentiraient berne et bâle à
moi je me sens berne et un meilleur
choix
présidente qui sort ce avec une salle à
construire baby mini c'est mal conseillé
c'est comme si elle qui gère les
journalistes
auraient été une
3è 4è conseillère savourer pu poser
d'autres questions mais là ces concerts
de la com qui pose question oui ça
m'énerve une certaine indulgence ici
parce que dit souvent que les français
n'ont plus confiance dans les
journalistes c'est à cause de monsieur
thomas sotto pleine action c'est celle
qu'on lui vient entre les journalistes
le pouvoir
ça ça des crimes et délits bien de mire
nous en étant tellement excessif et toi
tu avais rien dé toute façon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors l'elysée matignon a le bar
télévision a dit qu'il y avait encore au
point d anthologie qui dit il ont
précisé aussi ce qui relève de la vie
privée doit rester privé dans l'escalier
mais si ça apporte quoi vous c'est pas
un désaveu de france télévisions je
trouve qu'il a bien fait de se retirer
évidemment maintenant les gars étaient
contraints par la direction oui sauf que
là est là pour dire qu'il a pas dit il
et on dit écoutera frères ccx à léon
bayada et voilà c'est injuste donc ça
veut dire oui c'est un
joueur parisien mais qu'est ce que c'est
bon car le plus mais oui il a demandé on
a demandé la paille choix mais trouve
que c'est injuste car voilà quelques
regrets oui la presse journalistes et
c'est quelqu'un qui aurait su faire la
part des choses donc il
n'est pas d'accord regardez façon lui
pour faire couler un peu
et vous les médias
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je dis tout haut j'aimais beaucoup il
était à europe 1 lorsque j'étais europe
1 et j'étais un garçon très sympathique
vraiment où vous voyez tout le temps est
il une offre d un élu est arrivé de me
demander des petits services oui est ce
que tu peux regarder si je peux faire un
petit peu plus un peu plus sa europe 1
être la nina il m'a demandé pas mal de
services g j'ai toujours essayé de lui
rendre et à chaque fois je vais pas me
plaisait et à chaque fois qu'ils aient
une interview de quelqu'un il me mettait
une cartouche donc j'ai dit où il a pas
de mémoire où il est con comme une [ __ ]
et m'a écouté je pense que à mon avis
n'a pas de mémoire donc là ça va lui
faire du bien de travailler un petit peu
de chez me voilà et de faire coter les
matins de se réveiller tout peut-être
qu'il va retrouver la mémoire parce que
je l'aimé beaucoup et c'est vrai qu'on a
été très sympa du tout les mêmes reçu
oui comme nous parler de son handicap
exact exactement on a toujours été très
sympas avec moi à chaque fois ils ont
mis des cartouches donc voilà donc à mon
avis où il a perdu la mémoire ou bien je
sais pas il est trop amoureux et il n'a
plus de discernement il reste gentillet
du 20h aussi un gars qui reste joker
même dans les jeux nord-sud jus de
fruits
merci j'ai compris
avait dû partir d'un ce jour non mais
c'est vrai mais tu tombes à s'auto je
vous dis je l'aimé bien j'ai été déçu et
bilingue il s'habille toujours très
sympa avec lui et il m'arrive voilà qui
est votre copine isabelle saporta
quitter rtl apple a commencé à sortir
avec jane do on va faire toutes les
histoires
parce que bammer aut 6-1 elle est sortie
avec
charles pasqua à l'époque
ça peut être du coup peut-être quelqu'un
qui est pas bien humainement mais un
très bon journaliste
mais il est bon annick et t mobile
avaient été déçus ce pas là étaient
déçus exactement mais moi quand je donne
beaucoup ouais j'aimerais juste qu'on me
rende juste un petit peu or voilà merci
c'est pas de moi non merci je ne me
rendais rien